amen
love you
[Music]
it's what i mean
i love it
who's connor
corey's my boyfriend
and what do you want to do with him
i think you're a bit too young to get
married
[Music]
you can't get married please
hi guys i'm gonna prank my mom hey mom
yeah say crap say crack my finger why
just say it
crack my finger say it backwards think
about crap
daddy can you say
road
daddy can you say path
doesn't
[Music]
this morning at school and i took it to
miss mcdonald and i said
i've done she said you've not done
look
i've done i've done more than one
sentence and she said
you aren't
well
and then i said look there's full stops
for you
you'll be on two pages if you've done
more than one sentence and it says just
put it in box i'm sick of hearing you
now and so a pretty inkbox and i thought
i have done when she marks it she'll be
surprised and she was so sorry to me
i will walk out of here and look
and you fly up to him and leave a rocket
and see wow
you're too young to see god i want to
see god
[Music]
do you love do you love mommy
no do you love daddy yeah do you love
brookie
do you love finley
do you love mcdonald's
i said you're not having any of my
inheritance is what i said
so
you'll cave me down if i give you the
money
you just want all the money
you sure
that's not really kind to me is it
so if i let you have all the inheritance
you'll be happy
let's share with toby
okay so you told me she had inheritance
that made me happy
okay
amen
love you
[Music]
maddie who made all this mess of toilet
paper
the ghost did it did you see him
did he come in here and he made all this
mess
so where is he now he
he did it he did it here when we
[Music]
why didn't you tell the ghost that he
shouldn't make a mess
we did
because he said sorry so then you let
him go
yeah and you didn't tidy his mess
no you guys didn't your night
i think you guys did it
[Music]
no
[Laughter]
again
never no
now you're too little to have a
boyfriend no i want a little boyfriend
like me like me
me a little boyfriend
no why do you think you need a boyfriend
madison
because i love boys
[Laughter]
oh wait till we tell daddy
help us do we say calendar calendar okay
louis say advent calendar okay
right there his is detective ag and his
first name is bob right
right like
right
right here
like what yes what is it
butter
it's white peanut butter
what have you got your toast
peanut butter
is it nice
yum
it's peanut butter peanut butter
[Music]
why don't you want to go
we go out to bed
wow what do you want to do
you're gonna go to the pub yeah
but what do you want to do in the pub
[Music]
you want to do what
[Music]
you want to drink beer yeah where what
at the pub yes
[Music]
[Music]
what is going on here
what's it called what's that film called
you were talking about charlie and the
chocolate factory and who owns the
chocolate
factory miss mr willy wonka
it's wee wonka
[Music]
master willie
wonka
say good morning everyone
help
what
um can you go can you walk behind there
why we could um but because one
in a mountain
she has a what
in her mouth
oh ron has a stick in her mouth look at
that
you might absolutely that's why you're
that's why you're on the naughty list
trust me well that's why you're on a
naughty list because you're being
naughty right now so you're going to be
a naughty list if you keep talking like
that no no because father christmas has
not been very nice to me because you're
being naughty so you're on a naughty
list
well i'm not i'm on the good place
actually you're not cause you you're not
cause you ain't being good
i am on a good list
if you get saying that word again and
again and again i'm not annoying this
father christmas
rung me last night when i was at work i
said you better tell jackson to start
being a good boy or he's going to stay
on the naughty list and he won't i get
no presents for christmas that's what he
said to me so you've got to start being
a good boy
[Music]
what do you do if a man offers you
lollies
that's good no you can't find mummy
[Music]
what do you do if a man offers you
[Music]
lots and lots of watermelon and fruit
that's good no you can't find mommy
why what if someone says hey do you want
to come and see my puppies what do you
say
please give me that
no you can't find mommy
what do you do if he says hey i've got
lots of lollies in my car do you want
some what do you say
[Laughter]
are you happy that we home
timmy
[Applause]
[Music]
oh